so aside from running stage 32 he's also
a screenwriter actor voiceover yeah how
is networking helped you with let's say
the screenwriting how is that
transitioned you it's made all the
difference in the world the you know I'm
a represented screenwriter because of
social media there were a lot of things
that led to that I placed second in the
creative world Awards out of I think it
was 5,000 scripts obviously getting
exposure from that the exposure that I
got from that led to a couple of people
that I knew through social media there
was somebody who was interested they
knew somebody that I knew on social
media that person went to bat for me
with somebody else and all of a sudden
that was getting this web that I talked
about earlier office and this was an
expansion that led me to David
Greenblatt and you know David found that
endeavor back I think in the you know
late 80s would ever sold at William
Morris which is won't William Morris
Endeavor he's one of the cofounders of
it he's been repping Shane black since
1984 David wasn't somebody I was getting
in front of without people vouching for
me people that I had cultivated
relationships with on social media who
knew this person who knew that person
who wanted to read the work now who
wanted to take a look at it and who
finally got it to a director who was
wrapped by David and the directors of
the David you need to read this and a
day later the director was on a plane
out here and I was sitting in front of
David and three weeks later I was
wrapped it doesn't happen without social
media it just doesn't but it also
doesn't happen had I not called the bit
of those relationships had I not worked
the social media side of things
and you know there's no bigger shining
example than that you know for me I mean
it just doesn't happen without it but
also the hours that you put into writing
as well well absolutely and again it's
that balance it's that like I said it's
like to me it's that 50/50 balance like
I spent fifty percent of my time on my
craft outside of stage 32 of course
fifty percent of my time in my craft but
I when I sit down when I have the hours
to work on my creative career I spend
fifty percent of the time on the stuff
I'm working on it
means I'm going to acting classes I'm
going to acting classes but maybe during
that time I'm also networking I spend
the other 50% of the time trying to
network ok it's so important it's so
vital everything good that has happened
has come through for me anyway at least
over the last few years even going back
in a roundabout way to the film I
produced I was a producer on the went to
Sundance that was right at the beginning
of stage 32 and there was somebody that
I met on the site that actually under
playing a big part in that film going
forward it was somebody that was ended
up being an ally of mine in the
production so and that led to something
else later on it's and then he
introduced me to people and on and on
and on so it is it's a so vital and
vitally important that you put in the
time it's just you know it that's a
perfect example of what I mean by it's
who you know as well the people that got
me to David let's say you know it's my
screenwriting manager they weren't
necessarily big players they were people
that believed in what I was doing they
were people that knew other people they
were people that went to those other
people and said hey you know the work is
there this just happened he just
finished second you need to look at this
and they said ok because I was vouched
for through these other people and that
doesn't happen without social media if
there was a PI piece of the percentage
of your day that you spend on social
media and I know this is getting really
technical but what like just a rough
estimate it's tough for me to say that
because I spend a lot of time on it as a
CEO of stage 32 so I spent a lot of time
helping people on the site answering
questions and you know even just
contributing in the forums and stuff
like that but you know again I try to
take half of my creative day if I know
if I have like six hours to which I very
rarely do if I know if I have an hour
you know I spend a half hour writing or
a half hour moving a project one for
example like right now I'm working on
producing a project and I'm probably
going to write the screenplay on it
where you know book needs to be optioned
and we've been working with the
attorneys and working with everything
you know along those lines if I have two
hours to spend on that I'm hoping and
get through the work part of that in an
hour you know to get that thing moving
and I'll spend the next hour networking
you know I'm in and trying to get back
to people and people who sent me Network
requests and looking at who these people
are and if they're worth you know me
accepting into the network and on and on
and on so you know it or you know even
if it's well it's actually a really good
example I know with this particular
project I went and found another
producer through the site who had
recently optioned the book and even
though I had been down through this
process before he was working in a lot
of new media spaces a lot of online and
I wanted to go to him and say tell me
your experiences this is a person I met
through the site and we were able to
communicate get on the phone you know we
talked online but then we got on the
phone and you know he gave me his
experiences which was very helpful
actually so again that communication
doesn't happen if I'm not spending the
time networking or going and looking for
that
you